[Music]
throughout this month and during this
newscast we have been sharing stories
about the remarkable women of southern
nevada
and these four ladies were highlighted
out of hundreds of nominees that
you sent to us and one of them will be
chosen to participate in the next star
woman of the year show so i'm so excited
to announce
that out of all the incredible stories
that we've heard the women we featured
the women we couldn't feature
the remarkable woman just one from las
vegas
is sitting right next to me and that is
trudy park killman
[Applause]
congratulations
we tried so hard to keep this as a
surprise i can tell you're surprised
we did it we did it congratulate trudy
you deserve it you're a
remarkable woman and we are so excited
to honor you
oh my goodness thank you so much i will
give you a second to take a breath
these gorgeous flowers are not just for
decoration these are for you i want you
to take them home
and enjoy them just a little something
for you these gorgeous flowers but
beyond that we've got more
there's always more right now we would
like to introduce our general manager
actually before that don't forget you're
going to be in a nationwide virtual
event
recognizing women from cities all across
100 all across the country more than a
hundred cities
so trudy we want to celebrate you all
that you've done because you helped
fight homelessness here in southern
nevada
so now i would like to bring in our
general manager lisa howefield
she has a special gift for you lisa
congratulations trudy on being named
our remarkable woman for las vegas we
know you spend a lot of time
trying to raise money for your charity
and we think this should help out with
your cause
on behalf of klas tv8 and nexstar media
group we are presenting
your charity with a check for one
thousand dollars
thank you so much for the amazing work
you're doing in our community
denise i'm going to send it back to you
because i understand
we do a thousand dollars that's amazing
yes we are so excited lisa thank you
um trudy uh we are so excited to honor
you a thousand dollars
and we've got some special messages uh
we're going to start off first
with cbs this morning's gail king who
has this word for you
trudy trudy trudy talking to you
congratulations
on being las vegas remarkable woman what
a story you have
you were nearly homeless you had to pick
yourself up and start the compassion
initiative lv
what does that do helping people in need
show such resilience
so while on covet lockdown you and your
team
serve meals out of the back of your hope
van you then
provided survival gear for people
sleeping outside
you then made computer bundles for
families homeschooling
you then purchased bus passes for those
who wanted to return to their families
when you add all that up sounds like
remarkable to me and that's why we
salute you today
you are truly remarkable trudy
congratulations again
and good luck as you now compete for
nexstar's woman of the year
okay now i'm crying here here
oh my gosh gail king all right we have
another message for you from nevada
senator catherine cortez masto
oh my gosh my hero i'm senator catherine
cortez masto
and i want to thank trudy park hillman
for the amazing work she has done in las
vegas to help others
from providing needing families with
clothing and toiletries
to making meals for thousands to
distributing holiday gifts
trudy has made it her mission to bring
light into others lives
i am so proud to see one of our hometown
heroes being recognized
and the real winners are so many people
across las vegas whom trudy has helped
thank you trudy for everything that you
do and congratulations
no and you know such you said that she's
one of your heroes she is one of my
heroes as a matter of fact her office is
helping me right now navigate another
situation
with social security for my youngest
son kendall so she has been a go-to for
me since we moved back to vegas in 2013.
we've got another go-to lady in our
community who wants to congratulate you
and that is congresswoman dina titus
killman i was so
touched to hear your story and i want to
extend my most heartfelt
appreciation and congratulations
as you know better than most this past
year has been an incredibly difficult
one
for so many in our community and in this
time of overwhelming need
you have risen to the occasion and made
your impact felt more strongly than ever
before
even more impressively you have managed
to do it all
without many resources or much fanfare
i am moved by your compassion and your
generosity
and i am inspired by your work ethic and
your tenacity
truly you are the definition of a
remarkable woman
and we agree so we heard both of those
ladies all three ladies talk about what
you do
tell our viewers at home a little bit
about the compassion initiative lv and
and why you started it because you
didn't really set out to do something
like that
no i i truly believe in life that you
you have a journey and you're
predestined for that journey so
i moved back here in 2013 with my two
boys
and uh some circumstances
led us to in a situation where we
needed housing like very quickly my
social security had not been in place
and we were just receiving my husband's
death benefits which is not enough to
survive in vegas
and so i reached out for the first time
in my life
for services and i was
my job hit the floor when i was told
that it was going to take
us three years to get housing and
i asked them so what do i do in the
meantime
and they honestly did not have an answer
for me
so the boys and i had a discussion
um and we decided that once
we were financially stable and i was not
facing homelessness myself that we were
going to get involved and start giving
back
and that's what we did so six years ago
i got involved with working with street
dogs
and one thing led to another and we
parted ways amicably and i
started on my own journey and i
have been forever grateful for the last
six years
those people have rescued me
as much as i have rescued them or
our family has a lot of medical issues
and
with the death of my husband 12 years
ago
it's very challenging and this has given
me an opportunity
to step outside of my space
and give me a purpose
because i at one point did not have one
i felt very defeated and
i'm just i'm so grateful and honored
and thank you well we are grateful and
and honored to be able to do this and
recognize you as the remarkable woman
here in las vegas out of hundreds of
nominees
and just as we can hear from the women's
testimony uh
earlier you deserve it enjoy your moment
thank you
yes and that thousand dollar check is
going to go a long way absolutely
absolutely thank you so much you have
done all of that while at the same time
raising your family
as a single mother your family is here
by the way
i'm sure that they're definitely proud
of you hopefully equally as surprised as
you were today
so thank you thanks again for all of
your family to be here we had the chance
to feature really a handful
of wonderful remarkable women so thank
you so much we posted all four
of their stories on 8newsnow.com